we're surrounded by statistical claims
whether it's a striking graph going
viral on social media
a politician claiming that life has
gotten 62 percent better while they've
been in office
or just something every day like a piece
of economic data
the numbers are everywhere
[Music]
so what should we think about them
here's one approach
don't trust any of them mutter something
about
lies damned lies and statistics or joke
that
98 of statistics are made up on the spot
that seems smart after all nobody likes
to be taken for a fool
but we can't just reject all statistics
equally statistics can show us things
about the world that we can't perceive
in any other way
instead we have to exert a bit of brain
power to figure out
what is true and what is not
that sounds hard but perhaps it's not as
hard as you might think
so here are three easy rules to make
statistics add up
the three c's of data wisdom
first be calm most statistics come
packaged up with emotional baggage
they're supposed to make us
angry or joyful or afraid
staggering deficits shocking rates of
crime
inspiring sums raised for good causes
these emotions are why numbers go viral
on social media
the reason they end up in the headlines
there's nothing wrong with feeling
emotions
they don't help us think clearly so
before you share a claim that has you
hot under the collar
take a moment to notice your instinctive
reaction
from rage to denial to vindication
once you've noticed it look at the
statistic again
it may seem different now second
get context for example when the uk
health secretary said in 2020 that the
nhs would save
a hundred million pounds over five years
if everyone who was
overweight lost a few pounds what should
we make of that claim
what does he mean by overweight for
example
and what evidence does he have to
support this claim
but the most important piece of context
is simply to understand whether
a hundred million pounds is a big number
it sounds big but there are 67 million
people
in the uk so a hundred million pounds is
just one pound fifty each
you can figure that out on your phone
now remember that one pound fifty each
was
spread across five years so that's 30
pence per person
per year the health secretary then said
that if every overweight person lost
some weight
the nhs would save the equivalent of 30
pence per uk resident per year
not a lot statistics can be a very
complex subject
you can get a long way with simple
questions about context
what's being measured here is it going
up or going down
is it big or small what's the source of
the claim
you don't need a lot of fancy maths just
a search engine
the back of an envelope and a curious
mind
which brings me to the third important
principle
be curious when we use a number as a
weapon in an argument
or a prop for our preconceptions we
learn nothing
instead we should think about statistics
as a tool to understand the world
like a telescope for an astronomer ask
yourself
what a statistical claim is really
telling you about the world
and what questions it inspires
of course we don't have time to do all
this for every claim we see
so a final habit is to ask yourself
whether the source of a statistical
claim
is respecting the three c's a good
journalist will help you be calm
will give you context and will feed your
curiosity
a viral gotcha circulating on twitter or
whatsapp
will often do the opposite we shouldn't
just accept
statistics unthinkingly but neither
should we dismiss them without thinking
either
three simple habits be calm get context
and be curious can help the world add up
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification
each time we upload a new video